let's go to your voicemails two one nine
two david p the infamous troy york who
has called in under various pseudonyms
cecil brewster he has a hispanic name
that he calls in under anyway he called
in again saying that he is not watching
the show anymore apparently because it's
fake news gap admin I know I I did not
listen to your show today well I'd be
willing to say that you started to show
off was down mentioning Donald Trump in
the first sentence and have your show
was fake news precisely hell yeah how it
wasn't a quarter of the show that was
fake news yesterday it wasn't 75% of the
show exactly half of the show was fake
news what's the problem because how do
you know which happened is arrested now
you don't know what to believe
well apparently it was the first half
because he didn't like how the show he
knew started all right Troy very very
interesting
MVP caller for sure on the bonus show
today
Oregon may soon decriminalize heroin
cocaine and meth or at least reduce the
criminalization of it former President
Jimmy Carter has made a solar farm to
power half of the city and the Third
Circuit Court of Philadelphia has
determined you I don't know who you is
but you in if you're in the United
States have the right to film the police
and that is a very very important
declaration which we will dig into on
today's bonus show sign up get instant
access to the bonus show as well as the
world's famous commercial free access
pass at david pakman.com slash
membership coupon code is available
I voted 17 patreon is available
patreon.com slash david pakman show for
those smaller pledges of a dollar or two
a month we will talk to you on the bonus
show